[Music]
okay the sunni 2005
from i believe that's sri lanka
okay let's go e4 e5
knight f3 knight c6
and we are facing the scotch d4
okay
uh well obviously here we we play e
takes d4 that's what we do and the
scotch gambit would be bishop c4
there we go we're facing the scotch
gambit
all right i guess
one thing that we could try to do is i
could try to play a bad line of the
scotch gambit for black
and then try to recover from it
so
black has two main approaches in this
position the first is knight f6
and a lot of you guys might know that
that leads to e5 and then black has this
move d5
that's what i actually play
the other approach is to cling to this
pawn on d4 and go bishop c5 this is what
we're going to do now
and white's main move is to respond with
c3
and that contains a pretty vicious trap
which we're going to fall into
deliberately
so the way to play here for black is to
go knight f6
and that has a possible transposition to
the italian c takes d4 bishop before
check
what we are going to do
is something that is not advised and
that is d takes c3
now as
our opponent is thinking yeah so she
knows
the correct approach bishop takes f7
check
and this forces our king out of its
shell and the bishop on c5 is picked up
with queen d5 track and white is
considered to be clearly better in this
line so that is an instructive blunder
how bad is it for black it's not as bad
as some i think books have said black is
by no means losing but black is much
much worse
so first order of business is to figure
out where we should put our king
obviously not on g6 or f6 we're going to
get mated
the real question is do we go e7 do we
go e8 or f8 who can tell me the best
square and why
so we should choose the rel the safest
square relatively speaking
so i think some of you might be saying
okay so
let's think logically if we go king f8
that allows white to take on c5 with
check so we don't want that so therefore
we should go king e
and after king e queen takes e5 we have
a temple what can we do with this tempo
well we can take on b2 and preserve our
extra pawn but that's actually flawed
logic
the problem there is that even though
yes you do in a pawn the bishop comes
out to be two and i i hope you guys can
see how dangerous that becomes that
bishop immediately attacks g7
black is going to get smothered there so
the point here is not to cling to your
extra pawn it is to make the king as
safe as possible and so the move king f8
is actually the correct one
in f8 is relatively speaking a better
square for the king
why is that
because on e8 the king
so think about it this way when you play
king e8 and then you put the pawn on d6
that pawn on d6 becomes a hook
and white can exploit that hook by
pushing e5
and if you think five seven moves in the
future that king on ea might be caught
on the crossfire of a vicious attack
down the e file on f8 it is temporarily
safe
from
anything terrible that might happen on
the e-file for the time being does that
make sense
so here we go d6 covering the check and
opening up our bishop
and when you have a situation like this
your king is weak you have to first and
foremost develop as quickly as possible
and as actively as possible to
give yourself a little bit of time that
you can then use to for instance castle
by hand
so what should we start with
when my headphones died
what should we start with yeah so we
should start with knight f6 we should
start with knight f6 that hits the pawn
on e4
and then this bishop could come out to
g4
and in such situations you should always
be aware of the
eventual plan of castling by hand moving
the king back up to f7
swinging the rook to f8 or e8 and then
tucking the king back to g8
unfortunately the immediate king f7 is
bad
who can tell me why why can't we go king
f7 here and then move the rook aside
because of knight g5 very nice so
logically what move comes to mind i'm
not saying that this is the best move
but it is a candidate mode what can we
try yeah we can play h6 first
now you might say well doesn't h6 weaken
the g6 square you know can't white play
something like knight h4 yes white can
but then we go king f7 and that square
is going to be protected
let's give it a shot let's go h6
i'm not developing the light square
bishop because i feel like
castling by hand is the top priority
here if we can squeeze that in
everything else is going to fall into
place
now a very skilled opponent is is going
to find a way to deter us from from
doing this
but let's see if she's up to the task so
king f7
and then another point of not developing
the bishop is that if our opponent gives
us a queen check on either of these
squares we can cover it with our bishop
very important detail without which this
wouldn't work
hopefully everything is making sense so
far b3
that is not a particularly scary move
and it seems like we will accomplish our
first
aim now where should we go with the
stroke should we go to f8 or should we
go to e8 and you could make a case for
both but what's the more natural move
yeah the more natural move is to go to
e8 because at least the rook is doing
something there it's pressuring the pawn
and our opponent i like what she's doing
she's going to put the bishop on b2
that's going to create a battery and
that's going to immobilize the knight on
f6
nonetheless we have accomplished
something very serious our king is now a
lot safer than it was on f8
but we're still worse
why are we worse well first of all
white's got a very nice pawn on e4 which
could
potentially advance to e5 and of course
the main reason that we're worse is
because of this battery this battery is
a permanent strain on our position it
doesn't allow our knight to move
and if this knight is eliminated then
we're going to have to deal with very
serious threats along the diagonal
okay
how should we continue
well there's a couple of approaches we
could take but i think the time has come
for us to complete our development i
think the time has come for us to
complete our development
what does that mean what move does that
entail
yeah 95 is another candidate move trying
to put more stuff on that diagonal i'll
explain after the game why i think it's
a bad move
or why i think it's not not the right
approach
yeah bishop g4
alternatively we could play bishop e6
but let's try to play with maximal
activity and so that means bishop g4
so i was asked to explain king g8 the
point of king jade is just to physically
get the king as far away from harm as
possible
if you think about it when the king sits
on f7
it's a lot more susceptible to all sorts
of tactics right knight g5 95 if the
center opens up it's closer to the
center physically the further away the
king is from the center the safer it is
as a rule of thumb that's why you castle
in the first place because it's far
harder to open up the king side and get
your pieces to the king side than it is
to get your pieces to the center
okay what do we do now queen c2 is an
interesting move this i guess opens up
the bishop
and i suppose there are a couple of
things that we could do here
the simplest idea is probably to connect
our rooks
we should probably get this queen out of
d8
and put it on a somewhat more active
square
so
there's a little maneuver that i'm
thinking about where do you guys think
we should park our queen not on the next
move but ultimately
what's an what's a nice square for the
queen
and be very careful because if you go
queen d7 we allow bishop takes f6 and
our pawn structure is ruined i don't
know if i'm prepared to allow that
i don't know if i'm prepared to allow
that so what should we start with we
should start with queen e7
and eventually yeah so eventually we
should get our queen to f7 that's the
square i'm looking at not g6 but f7 why
f7
because from f7 the queen controls the
knight on f6 it controls the f file and
it allows the rooks to breathe and it's
also just physically provides protection
to the king
so let's start with queen e7
now you might be thinking well am i not
worried about e5 i am worried about e5
that's a worrisome move
but i think we'll be able to survive the
impact i think we'll be able to trade
and then move the queen aside and i just
don't see
that that's
that dangerous
yeah
i think it's yeah she's playing very
very well but i think so far we're
we're doing decently in terms of
recovering
jtd thank you so much
you are the freaking man
i don't even know what to say thank you
thank you so much for those watching on
youtube we had an absolute sub explosion
the stream jd gifted 569 subs
in one stream so that's why i'm freaking
out about it
thank you thank you
have a great night thank you lenard for
the prime
not done more subs
yeah i know he's easy it's crazy so
our opponent is contemplating our next
move
um
we will put the queen on f7 and then
ultimately how can we continue improving
our position well we can potentially
double on the e file knight d4 is a
great move
it it gets the knight
out of the purview of the bishop and now
the bishop kind of just looks dumb on g4
just shooting into thin air right
so 94 is an impressive move
now
we should probably trade
we should probably trade
because if we don't trade then we're
going to lose a pawn and a lot some of
you might be thinking about knight e5
but as i just explained in the last game
knight on e5 is often unstable and it
could be chased away with f4 why would
we want to allow that right
so let's take
yeah
the tangsta asks if you to look at this
position fresh what factors into your
evaluation i'll explain that more
carefully after the game
like why how do i know that white is
better here
even though i kind of talked about that
a little bit
all right now there's there are some
issues that we're facing here if we
follow through on our plan if we play
queen f7 who can tell me what nasty
response white has to that move
when f7 allows something we don't want
to allow
now think about type 2 on defended
pieces and pawns this pawn on c7 is a
type 2 it's protected by the queen the
queen is actually overextended right now
because it's defending the knight and
protecting the pawn and so bishop takes
f6 is a positional threat that would
essentially force g takes f6
so then you might be saying well that
means we have to defend our c pawn so
should we go rook aca
well no right we don't necessarily want
to tie down an entire rook can we do it
in a more economical manner
we can go c5 but i would argue that c5
really weakens the d6 pawn yes it's with
tempo
but we're going to have that permanent
weakness on d6 i think c6 is a better
idea because
why isn't this still a weakness it is
still a weakness but now
it's far more realistic that and far
more likely that we'll be able to go d5
so
it isn't in such positions when you're
struggling when you're worse it's
you know you don't want to fall in love
with moves with tempo right c5 is a
classic case of one move itis yeah you
attack the bishop but you're creating
more permanent weaknesses i'm not saying
c5 is a terrible move i think it's
maybe almost as good as c6 but i think
this is a little bit safer because it
creates the possibility of going d5 in
fact d5 is almost a threat in this
position e takes d5 we can take the rook
okay
so let's see what our opponent comes up
with here i think the best approach for
white would be probably to go f3 or h3
and then maybe activate this knight on
c4
another great move would be rookie three
the move i'm really worried about is
rookie three
lifting the rook up to g3 okay so h3
happens
h3 happens
okay
now i suppose we move our bishop where
should we move it
bishop h5 is one possibility
but i think it's safer to keep your
pieces
uh closer to the center maybe clustered
together so that they control more
important squares
if you think about it okay so the knight
wants to go to c4
i don't know why you guys are
are thinking about bishop d7 to me that
move looks quite awkward
in fact it the move bishop d7 will make
it harder for us to defend d6 it'll
invalidate the mover kta bishop e6 yeah
i'm not sure why
you know why people were deterred from
this move but i think bishop e6 is the
most natural in fact it also cuts into
the pin which which makes it less urgent
for us to move the queen aside
thank you chocolate boy
yeah so that's an important point it
blocks the battery it does
but how should i put it that's not the
most important thing it's it's not like
we're trying to win the e4 pawn the e4
pawn is perfectly well defended
right so
yes it makes the rook temporarily maybe
a little bit passive but we're adopting
a defensive posture here um and and the
point is to control as many squares as
possible okay so e5
striking in the center we have to take
that pawn
and then perhaps it might be a good good
time to move our queen away from
e7 now bishop h5 was fine bishop h5 was
also fine but i think bishop b6 is just
a little safer
queen versus two rooks totally depends
on the concrete situation it can be good
it can be bad it can be anything in
between
there's no
general formula on evaluating that rook
takes e5
quite clearly
we have to move our queen away
where should we move it
where should we move it and a couple of
squares comes to mind we can play queen
d6 and attack the bishop
green d6 has the advantage of being with
tempo
the disadvantage of queen d6 is that the
queen
is a little bit further from our king
than i would like it to be i i feel like
we should stick to our destination from
earlier i feel like we should play queen
f7 that queen just seems really really
solid on that square
that queen just seems really solid on
that square after rook 81 we are still
worse we have definitely not equalized
but we are
making progress
okay
so we're expecting rook a
e1 and i just i just feel safer knowing
that my queen is is protecting the g7
pawn and in case that the knight on f6
is traded in case something like this
happens
i hope i'm making logical sense just
good to keep the queen closer to our
king
and by the way you should notice the
presence of opposite colored bishops
what does this tell you well as i've
shared several times before in the end
game opposite-colored bishops provide
very much raj tendencies as you guys
know but in the middle game
opposite-colored bishops often favor the
attacker
in fact they produce something opposite
to a drag tendency they
they make it a lot easier to attack
because
intuitively we have nothing with which
to control the dark squares
alright so the natural thing to do here
is to move the bishop to d5 and offer a
trait of rooks
let's calculate bishop d5 rook takes the
a check rook takes c8
rook takes the a check and we run into a
small problem queen takes e8
and at the end of that line what do we
need to reckon with what does white have
at the end of the line bishop takes f6
as possible but then we play g takes f6
and here's the thing because so many
pieces have been traded i'm far less
concerned about our pawn structure
getting damaged
but what other move does white have in
that situation
white also has bishop takes a7
but let's calculate one move further
than that so again bishop d5
rook takes c8 try to visualize this rook
takes c8 one takes c8
queen takes e8 bishop takes a7 and what
active possibility do we have
no queen g6 is impossible the queen
controls that square
your queen is on e8 there are no rooks
on the board i'm talking about black
what can black do there
queen check very good you can give a
check on e1 or you can go queen e2
and it seems to me that the combination
of opposite colored bishops together
with our activity should give us
sufficient compensation to make a draw
and again i'm i have to say i'm very
impressed with our opponent's play
i mean she's keeping the pressure and
it's quite likely that this game is
going to end in a draw
okay
now nanuka says can't we take with the
knight yeah you can take with a knight
you can you can say i don't want to give
this pawn away at all i take with a
knight the downside of that is that you
yield the e file and i really really
don't want to give up give our opponent
full control of the e-file because if
the rook ever infiltrates to e7 we're
kind of toast
okay
so we're expecting rook takes e8 and
then we're gonna have a trade of rooks
and an end game
queen f5 putting more pressure that's
another really good move
but not as scary as i think it looks so
what should we do
well we should try to discharge the
tension right we have to start trading
pieces
the most traditional and the best method
of
dealing with pressure and dealing with
the dubious position is to trade
so we can either trade immediately rook
takes e5
or some of you are proposing the move
knight d7 which essentially forces a
queen trade but knight d7 doesn't work
concretely
d7 queen takes queen
and if you take with the king
then after the trade of rooks on e8
notice that that g7 pawn is going to
hang
that g7 pawn is going to hang because
our knight is no longer on f6
very good plus so therefore i think it's
sensible to take on e5 first
and after rook takes c5 knight d7 is
more sensible it forces the queen trade
and in the end game white's control of
the e file is going to be far less
important and far less concerning
so let's go knight d7
yeah she correct i mean everything that
white is doing here is good
and the end game is still going to be
slightly worse for us why do i say that
well because i think white's bishop is a
little bit better than our bishop how do
i know that well white's bishop is
actually doing more right it's it's
pressuring both of these pawns
and white also has control of the e file
so
we have a couple of problems left to
solve in the end game but we're very
very close to equalizing
yeah move order is super important like
do you take the rook first or do you not
i think people over complicate move
order
what you should the way you should think
about it is you know different move
orders allow different options right so
for instance knight 97 the immediate 97
allowed white to take on e8 twice that
was a completely different position do
not assume that different move orders
simply transpose into each other because
frequently they don't and that's where
the problems happen
okay
so what should we do now
well first let's let's try to figure out
what our opponent's ideas are rook f3 is
not a problem because our bishop
controls that square
ideally we would like to solve the
problem of our pawns that are located on
dark squares and that are pressured by
the bishop
so we can either play a6
but let's go full attack mode let's go
a5
if we're already pushing the a pawn then
we might as well
um we might as well try to create some
pressure on white's queen side right a5
a4 and maybe we can open the a file and
one day maybe we can attack that b3 pawn
thank you chestocho 94 very good move
wow
okay
that's the move i was worried about
because it essentially forces a trade
and the reason that it forces a trade is
because knight d6 is a very very nasty
threat it would win the b7 pawn that is
unallowable we have to take that knight
we have to take that knight oh oh
yeah bishop takes g7 there was rook g8
though i missed it but bishop takes g7
here i think we had rook g8 in response
okay
so
we have a very interesting end game it's
a bishop versus knight situation
we can certainly contemplate the move a4
but white responds with b4 and that
doesn't accomplish much so what comes to
mind here
no definitely our opponent is playing
you know the high 2000s level but
uh you know
we'll we'll take a look at the game for
sure
offer draw maybe i so i don't like c5 or
b5 i feel like pushing pawns is just
going to create further weaknesses also
remember that white is threatening
bishop takes g7 here
white is threatening bishop takes g7
and so
we can push the g pawn
but i like to move knight f6 here rookie
8 loses rookie 8 loses a pawn rook takes
c8 and bishop takes g7 i like the move
knight f6 it offers a trade the trade is
going to be good for us and that knight
is kind of used as a shield shielding us
from the bishop's pressure of g7 right
okay so rook f4 is something that i
think some of you guys might be
concerned with
um and
the reason for that is is why i can
follow up with bishop takes f6 but again
you have to remember that in the end
game pawn structure does not work the
same way that it works in the middle
game a pawn structure that involves
pawns on f6 and h6 would be unthinkable
in the middle game because our king
would be terribly weak but in the end
game it's totally fine
in fact it can even be better to have
these isolated pawns than it might be to
have consecutive pawns because they can
both be defended by the king from a
single square
and after the game i'll show you guys a
very interesting example of a situation
where it is easier to make a draw
when you have a quote-unquote terrible
pawn structure than when you have a good
pun structure so of course i'm not
saying that we should take g takes f6
here we should take with a king but
that's just something to keep in mind
and i think we have fully equalized it
took us 29 moves now we have an equal
and very draw stroke end game how should
we play it what should we do
well the first step is to activate the
rook right our rook is sitting on a8
it's not doing anything
let's get it to d8 and potentially let's
get it to d5
let's get it to d5
the other thing we could do is we could
start pushing our pawns we could play b5
and try to create a passer our ultimate
plan here is definitely to create a
passer b5 c5 c4
but if we push our pawns too fast then
they might become weak and white might
win them
so
we also could consider playing g5 and
and trying to slow down the progress of
white spawns
um
let's give b5 a shot this is an
ambitious move it weakens the c6 mod but
it might pay off in the end
does the queenside majority mean that no
pawn end games are very unclear because
both sides have an equivalent majority
right both sides have a three versus two
which means that pawn any pawn end game
is going to depend
very directly on
okay draw is offered let's play on
which is which means that any pawn end
game is going to depend on who
uh who has a better king placement who
has
uh faster probability of creating a
passer
okay
so the move c5 here would be
ooh
there there there
the move c5 is very interesting
and i think we can give it a shot let me
just calculate something
okay i'm gonna let's give it a shot
folks
this is a risky move
but it could pay off
who can tell me why it's risky what does
white have in this position what nasty
little move on the queen side and
anytime you have three pawns arranged
like this neither of them is defending
the other which means that moves that
carve out squares become dangerous white
has the move a4
it's not played our opponent goes rook
e3 ooh
okay
so if we play c4 i definitely think that
that's premature
because then after takes takes rook c3
our pawn is going to become more of a
weakness than a strength and so i think
we should take this opportunity
and play a move like g5 in order to
slow down the progress of white's pawns
or or we could play rook d4 rook d4 is
another good move
the problem with the rook d4 is it lets
white infiltrate to e8
i would like to start with g5 let's see
what our opponent does here
i think this is going to help in the
event of a pawn end game it's going to
help us slow down
the possibility of creating a passer now
of course we have to go rook d5 we have
to defend the pawn
and potentially we can even try to go h5
h4 this is called a deep freeze
right when two pawns control three pawns
okay king e3
so let's go
our opponent wants king e4 but d4 is not
very dangerous because we can give a
check on e5
so this might be a good opportunity to
play h5
but i also like the idea of centralizing
our king
let's let's centralize our king
okay
now
the problem here is that we cannot move
our rook and we want to move our work we
want to be able to move our rook so what
move comes to mind
no b4 is bad b4 is bad because it
because it
it disqualifies us from ever creating a
past pawn on the queen side
rook d1 blunders the pawn we have to
defend the pawn on c5 and that means
going king d6 now maybe the pawn end
game is winning for white i don't rule
that out
i don't rule out that rook d3 wins for
white i mean it's going to be very close
and i'm too lazy to calculate it if our
opponent beats us from the same game and
congrats
hats off
and she's probably calculating it right
now
okay
let me think
yeah this is dangerous
okay let's take it and go king e5
yeah this is a little bit i mean
thinking on king takes 250 i don't know
about that okay so king e5 a4 takes
takes h5
king c4h4 takes takes
p5
h385 ng2a6h3
that could end up being a draw
i mean this is hard so king d5
f4 takes takes h5 h4
c4 takes tanks king c3 king e4
he takes c14 takes the point b5 and g4
takes takes
b6
oh wait a second so let me calculate
that again
okay d5
f4 takes take c4
take six there can you three key four it
takes take p54 takes a 5 takes h4 16
wait now that was there there
okay let's tracking d5
i'll talk about this after the game but
this is like
we're playing uh
yeah very very strong
strong opponent
okay f4 is what i thought would happen
let's take it ago h5
yes c4 check
i thought i thought we win this actually
let's see who calculated correctly i
think we win oh my god
4h4 we win this
we win this
this is a classic h3 we promote and stop
hey queen that's exactly as i calculated
it
now this is this is good this is good
stuff and we we can get our queen to a
this would be a draw if white's king
landed on b8 but the king cannot get to
b8
now for the record i do think our
opponent is legit but just obviously
very very clearly highly underrated
wow
i mean look there's a lot of top moves
but there's also a lot of inaccuracies
and mistakes so i just think
our opponent is strong and underrated
and the move f4 actually loses
oh wow oh my god this is so cool
oh my this end game is so cool okay
we'll we have to dig into this
um
and again guys i always say this
you know there's a lot of underrated
people on chess.com
um there are definitely a lot of
cheaters on chess.com but
just
be careful about making these
accusations and
you know sometimes
even i obviously get suspicious when
it's a 1400 and you know they're playing
on equal terms with me
yeah like part of me is like well that's
weird at the same time you know these
longer games people are capable of
finding good moves and you should always
put yourself in the shoes of the person
who's playing and saying and say well
have you ever had a really good game how
would you feel if you know 2 000 people
made up their minds based on five good
moves that you played that you're a
cheater for sure
i think if you do that if you imagine
that you're that person
um
you know i'm not saying never be
suspicious of anybody
but you know just try to act based on
evidence that you can always plug the
moves into a computer
anyway sorry for the lecture let's get
into the game it's a very sensitive
topic because
you know suspicion is is often very well
founded but there's also a lot of
underrated and strong people so it's a
very difficult thing to kind of navigate
all right
so d4 we have a scotch gambit
bishop c5 c3 and dc3 is a mistake
um as far as i know maybe
maybe modern theory has found a way for
black to to get a decent position here
but practically speaking this is very
bad
and and the move here is knight f6
sorry let me reopen the game in an
analysis board
so the move here is knight f6
and um
e5 d5 and
you know stuff happens here
you can explore this on your own i'm not
too interested in talking about the
opening
yeah so rishidon asks what happens after
queen d5 here well who can tell me
you tell me you're [ __ ] on there are two
pieces that are attacked so one of the
ways to defend against the fork is to
ask yourself well can one of my pieces
defend both of the pieces that are being
attacked
the answer here is yes you can play
queen e7
and black is fine because you're gonna
go knight f6 on the next move and kick
away the queen
so bishop f7 is correct
okay
so again king e8 is in my opinion
inferior because the king
you know is closer to the center and can
be caught on the crossfire
so i think i i explained pretty deeply
all of these choices so let's go pretty
quickly through the opening h6 again
preparing to castle
preparing to castle
by hand
king f7 rookie 8 king g8
there is a question here about the move
knight e5
why didn't i play 95 to to try to plug
the diagonal
the reason is knight takes e5 and you're
in a tough spot because if rook takes e5
well that rook is not stable y can go f4
and if pawn takes e5 this pawn becomes a
very serious weakness how can white
attack it why can play either knight c4
or knight f3 and it's going to be very
difficult to defend this pawn and you
might have to play a move like this but
already i can play f4
and black's versus nightmare comes true
i mentioned that you can almost never
move this knight away from f6 if that
happens you're gonna be in big trouble
okay another question weren't you afraid
of queen b3 check before i played b3
yeah so queen b3 check is
a move that i was a little worried about
and i fully intended to sacrifice upon
had white played this
and then for instance we can go queen d7
and i would argue that yeah i'm sure
white is better why can evacuate the
queen through b5 but at the very least
we've gotten a lot of moves in
uh in the time that white has spent
evacuating her queen and we can go
rookie eight we can go rook b8 and i
think black has a very decent position
there is some compensation a little
compensation yeah
how important is being upon it down upon
at this level
um
not that intermountable i mean anywhere
20 2000 and under as a rough number you
know being down upon
and i'm not talking about a pawn end
game obviously uh being down upon let's
say in the opening or early middle game
is really not not a big deal not
something to to frighten about but you
shouldn't fret about it if you're a gm
either right once you blunder you just
have to accept it and and try to make
the most of it thank you lazan
so
maybe queen b3 was best you can check
this with a computer
did i see 22 2200
so bishop b2
bishop g4
queen drops back to c2 we go queen e7
again the point is to get our queen to
f7
knight d4 is a very nice move
now we play c6 again c5 would end up
weakening the d6 spawn quite severely
um queen c4 check there was also bishop
e6 okay so h3 bishop b6 now here
um
bishop h5 how do i explain this i just
feel like this bishop is
a little bit neither here nor there it's
just sort of sitting on a weird square
it's not really controlling any of the
light squares in the center the move
knight c4 becomes easier to play
does that make sense white can go g4
potentially i just feel like this bishop
could end up getting in the way i don't
think it's a big difference though
um
so does bishop f5 work here no he takes
f5 and
remember that white has made some luft
and also i can go knight f1 and a queen
and a piece for two rooks is way too
much of a price to pay
okay
so bishop e6
and
somebody asked me the question how do i
know that white is better as i indicated
the main reason is that you have
this monster bishop on d4
and if you think about it white's
control over the dark squares is more
impressive than black's control over the
light squares because white has the
possibility of playing e5 white is aimed
at black's king black isn't really aimed
at white's king
and in addition there's just differences
in piece placement white has this pawn
on e4 white's got a nice rook behind it
black's a little bit more passive in the
center these combination of things is
exactly what gives white the advantage
that's what the advantage consists of
it's you know
relatively small factors that taken
together result in a nasty position
okay why is c5 not brutal
what do you mean
for who
like why is it not that bad i'm not sure
what you're asking
for white well because of bishop b2
right white just drops the bishop back
i'm not sure what
why did you think this was brutal for
white
yeah that black has a weakness on d6
right a bigger weakness than if you play
c6
so that's the point
um
so c6 h3 bishop b6 e5 i think e5 was in
inaccuracy i think this was premature i
think that white should have just gone
rook ad1 and made small improving moves
and maybe going f4
okay so de5 rook takes e5 queen f7
dropping the queen away from the pin
then we have this mass trade so again if
we go knight d7 immediately
um
queen takes f7 is very unpleasant i mean
either we have to lose the a pawn or we
have to lose the g pawn in this case we
lose the g pawn there's a trait on e8
and then bishop takes g7
and if bishop takes f7 then there's rook
takes c8 and another bad choice if
bishop takes c then rookie seven if rook
takes c8
then white wins a7 and you might be
thinking well wait a second doesn't b6
trap the bishop but what you have to
understand about this construction
is two things first of all this bishop
is totally unassailable it cannot be ch
it cannot be attacked in order to attack
a black needs to get the king all the
way around which gives white plenty of
time to extricate the bishop and why
does several ways of doing that the
simplest is to go knight c4
but who can tell me what the alternative
way of getting this bishop out of a7 is
if knight c4 didn't exist if black had a
bishop on f7 let's say
let's say let's say we had this position
what should black do here what should
white do here
yeah white should start with a4
and then white should go b4 and then a5
essentially trying to get to this b6
pawn
okay
so for that reason we take the rook
first and then go knight t7 and let's
fast forward all the way to the pawn end
game because
i think at this point everything i was
doing is quite obvious knight f6 we have
a trade we activate the rook we start
pushing the pawns
we start pushing the pawns
now what's important to realize i mean a
lot of you were proposing the move
before why is b4 bat it's because it
creates a deep freeze situation where
the pawn on b3 is freezing both of these
pawns not allowing them to progress does
that make sense and
of course you want to preserve the
ability to create a past pawn here i
mean why else are we pushing these pawns
but before that
what was i planning against a4 here i
was planning a tactical response without
which i think black is in serious
trouble who can find it
so the drawback of a4 is that it
it weakens the b3 pawn
and that allows black to have this nice
tactic with c4
and if a takes b5 then black wins
connected passers and this is
unstoppable
so white should go here
but now we play b takes a4 we're
threatening to push this pawn so white
should probably go
c5 and now we can play the the cold
blood and move rook c8 the point being
in the event of a trade only black can
win
obviously because we are the ones with
an outside passer this should be a draw
but that's unpleasant for white right
so this is the line i calculated
our opponent went rookie three we took
this opportunity to freeze up white's
king side pawns
roxy through ricky pipe king e3 king e5
g3 was a nice move
because this essentially prevents any
h5h4 shenanigans
so again here
b4 is a knee-jerk reaction very bad move
because it only gives white a blockading
square and it makes it so much harder to
push these pawns
king activity is not
something that you know
you can retreat your king in end games
and end games just like in middle games
you have to be very concrete you know
you have to be goal oriented the goal
here is to free up this stroke we want
to be able to go rook d1 we want to be
able to go rook d4 so we have to protect
c5
and rook d3 i failed to properly
consider
i checked very briefly with the engine
it looks like this is a draw
but then there were several mistakes
so
the one thing i can tell you so we trade
we go king up to d5 this is pretty
obvious
now what other options were at our
disposal
how was i even thinking about this pawn
end game
let me try to paint this from a general
perspective to help you guys understand
how i was able to
gear my calculation in the right
direction even though i ended up making
a mistake
so
this is kind of an archetype this type
of quantum game is an archetype
it's it's it's a pawn race archetype how
do i know that there's going to be a
pawn race well there's very likely going
to be a situation where both sides
create a passer and then both kings end
up going to opposite flanks to pick off
the pawns and then at the end of the day
the question is going to be whose corner
pawn is going to be faster i'm sure you
guys have seen
these types of situations before how do
i know that both sides will create a
pass model because both sides have a
relatively symmetrical pawn majority
so black's going to go c4 at some point
and white's going to go f4 at some point
now the point is to
create that pass pawn to to set yourself
up as successfully as possible for the
pawn race what does that mean what does
that entail first of all that means not
pushing your passer prematurely if you
push your passer and if you create a
passer prematurely
that past pawn could end up being weak
and you might have to end up you know
saddling your king with the task of
defending that pawn
so we start with the move king d5
activating the king and of course
preparing c4
our opponent responds with f4 which
apparently is the losing move after g
takes f4 g takes f4
how do i explain the move h5 h5 is a
move that
prepares us for the pawn race
again i'm thinking of the future and in
the future i'm thinking of a situation
where both kings end up taking corner
pawns why does h5 make sense who can
explain that to me why why is it good
to induce h5h4
that's your queen this is our queen and
this literally just pushes the pawn
closer to promotion so that when we take
this pawn we're gonna have an extra
tempo in fact that is exactly what
happened
it's not really about waiting moves it's
if if possible we would have pushed our
pawn all the way to h4
now
amazingly the winning move fear
was before
it or so it appears let me open the
analysis and we'll analyze this with an
engine
okay so we have this situation our
opponent goes f4 no maybe it is a draw
now when you're analyzing pawn end games
with the engine
uh remember that this kind of evaluation
minus point 45 can be very misleading
because essentially it's either a win or
a draw
there's very
seldom going to be something quote
unquote in between so what minus point
45 might mean
is that the computer sees that there is
going to eventually be a transition into
a queen end game where both pawns
promote simultaneously and maybe black
is an extra pawn hence the quote-unquote
slight advantage but generally
this evaluation really means nothing
because pawn end games are essentially
deterministic right they can be
calculated to the very end
so that makes sense
so increasing depth is important this is
at depth 20. that's enough for us
because we're going to make moves
but take this with a grain of salt
so gfgf is logical
and now it says that b4 is the winning
move which is crazy to me
because this seems so counterproductive
like it actually prevents us from going
to c4 my guess is there might be some
sort of a zugzwang situation here
so let's see
first of all if white plays f5
we actually lose if we go king e5
and again we have a pawn race takes
takes here here here
and this is exactly what happened in the
game except with colors reversed because
we have to move our king aside
and just like in the final scene of
searching for bobby fischer
white promotes and stops black from
promoting
i mean this is easy to follow this is
very concrete and so for that reason
once again
what the computer is saying is rather
than going for the spawn immediately
we need to make we need to take care of
our future cells we need to start by
making this extra move and that's going
to give us that extra tempo in the pawn
race
okay so
if white plays h4
then we go king e5 we get the exact same
pawn race with an extra tempo and black
wins
and the same thing f6 is more resilient
because this pushes black's king
further away but it still doesn't help
takes takes
here here
here takes takes yeah and the rest is
easy takes takes
so
b4
um we talked about f5 now h5 is
brilliant
f6 king e6 king c4 takes takes king g5
and the rest is easy right takes takes
now
in such situations you don't want to go
to g2
um because you you run into promotion
with check anywhere but g2 you want to
go here
and this is winning again by a single
tempo i mean isn't this amazing and it's
all because of this move h5
not rushing to go after white's pawn but
setting yourself up for a successful
pawn race
now white doesn't have to go f5
in fact i was sort of out of the corner
of my eye worried about the move king e3
what happens here
well again it makes sense to go h5
if white does nothing then we go h4
and after king e3 we actually push c4
anyway
and this is a classic scenario where we
have the outside passer so we're going
to force white's king back to the queen
side
our king is going to go around and take
white's pawns
and the reason that white doesn't
promote is because we stopped the pawn
and we're just faster
in fact we're faster by only one tempo
takes takes f6
oh and this is amazing look at this so
if you play b2
there's simultaneous promotion in the
draw what do we have to do this is like
a study you go king e6
force the king to g6
if you do a lot of puzzles on chess.com
you'll see this theme and now you play
v2 and v1 with a check
amazing
so white's king cannot
cannot go to the king side which means
it has to go here
and that means we win the pawn race very
straightforwardly again
jesus
so for that reason
it would make sense for white to go h4
and try to stop black spawn from
progressing but we still go c4 and it's
essentially the same exact theme the
important part is that these pawns run
very very quickly nothing changes after
f5 king d5
in a certain way this helps black
because it it's easier now to capture
the spawn and again we have the same old
pawn race
sorry we have the same old pawn race
where black wins by a single tempo much
like in the game
okay
so the winning move i mean this is
incredible this is very very instructive
was b4 this just shows you how
irrational pawn end games can often be
and the mechanism is that this is
zugzwan this is actually zugzwan f5
there's king e5 and if the king moves
then it allows c4 if white could pass
white would actually be winning it's
it's a situation of mutual zugzwan
let me create a situation where it's
black to move there
no it's still a draw but
you know white's kind of in charge here
so you might be asking at this point
why was h5 a mistake
and amazingly according to the computer
at a low depth white had an only move to
draw and that was a4
okay so
the point is b takes a4 b takes a4 the
point is exactly the same as the point
of h5 white simply pushes the pawn
preemptively as far as it'll go white
sets herself up for the pawn race as
well
we play h4
and this turns out to be a draw let's
see how
he takes c5 king f4 oh but it's not to
go here
no that's actually not the idea
now you follow black's king to the king
side and you get this position
and this is a draw
and the reason this is a draw is because
black can uncage arcane we can uncage
our king we can go h3
but this is still a draw
and we have another race this time it's
a race to the king side
but white makes it in time d2 and by a
single tempo king c1 and you guys know
that this is a draw king b1
and after king a2 there's king c2 and
that is just so instructive
now why is a4 necessary
well
the reason it's necessary is because
here if we play c4 check
then white does in fact go for the pawn
race and this is where the point of a4
shines through this is a draw
and this is a draw in fact black is the
one who's got to be
well no
here here here and of course this is a
theoretical draw
but black hats ago king g2
this is an exception to the rule if you
try to play king g3 and say well i'm
going to put my king on a square
where white isn't able to promote the
check this is counterproductive because
the black king is not able now to reach
g1
um
so
so many cool ideas and so the move a4 it
appears drew the game and if c4 checked
then takes takes king c3 yeah that's
what we just talked about
so black's best attempt after a4
is to go ba ba4 ba-4h4 and force white
to find this incredible idea
of
taking this pawn and then pursuing black
swing back to the king's side
so our opponent played h4 and this is
already losing after c4 check this is
losing because the pawn race
is lost and if white goes king e3
we have several ways to win the simplest
being king e6
now c3 forcing the king back and this is
just as in the game the pawn race wins
for black ac3 king e4 and this is what i
had this is what i was calculating
when i entered the pawn end game like i
just i kept calculating and
recalculating this because if you make a
single mistake in your evaluation of the
pawn race and even people like magnus
have made this mistake before it's going
to go from a win to a loss it's
literally tempo for tempo
so
that is why pawn end games
you know to me are
the most fascinating type of engine
because you get these ideas and this is
just one end game there's end games that
are far more complex than this one
well yeah i just showed she could have
drawn her last opportunity to draw was
a4
it was in fact the only move a4 in this
position
what's
hopefully i mean you guys have to know
queen
versus upon end games the rule is that
corner pawns and bishop pawns are drawn
corner pawns and bishop pawns are drawn
um
and the the reason why is that well let
me show it really quickly just to round
it off
with certain exceptions with certain
exceptions
this is a draw is what i'm trying to say
uh white is going this way the reason
this is a draw and normally what is the
approach to winning when the pawn is in
the center
the point is that you keep checking
force the king to go behind the pawn
and then you inch your king closer and
closer to the pawn you repeat the
process as many times as it takes
so you start with a move like queen e4
check and one way or another you zigzag
your way toward the pawn boom boom
boom and this is what you do when white
is the d-pawn the problem is that with a
bishop on or with a corner pawn the king
hides in the corner this is not a
capability that white has with the
d-pawn
the queen takes c7 is stalemate black
can make no progress and if you imagine
that the pawn was on a7 it would be
exactly the same situation the queen is
unable to approach the pawn any further
without causing stalemate and so you
have to move the queen away
and white moves the king back to b8 and
there's just nothing that can be done
there's just nothing that can be done
so if you shift the pawn to the d-file
then the win is very simple queen c6
check it this is not stalemate the king
has a a
and so the procedure is you know you
move your king up
and then in fact the fastest who knows
what the fastest way to get the king
under the pawn is for black hint it's
not a check
this is just something that's good to
know the black's best move here's not a
check
it's queen
back to c7 and after king e8 you give
this check and now the queen is very
very close to zigzagging back to d6
king up
here
here this is the best procedure boom and
you guys should be able to see the
pattern and eventually you have several
ways to win i mean the simplest is queen
e6 and then king back to d6 and you won
the pawn
now you might be asking
is a corner pawn drawn in all
circumstances and the answer to that
question is no
the the corner and the bishop on
um
can can still be winning for the side
with the king
and let me give you guys a good
illustrative example of that under which
circumstances you might be asking
is a corner pawn still losing
well this is one of those circumstances
seems like a corner pawn situation
black's king is not that close and yet
black's king is close enough
to do a very thematic win what
essentially black has to do is allow
promotion
and then black still corners white's
king and queen
the simplest move here is king b5
white promotes you give a check the king
king c8 is most is the most resilient
move how should black continue here
the point is that if king b8
then king b6 and white has no checks
this is pretty awesome actually and
black's queen dominates
king c8
now if you go king b6 here then white
does have a check and white saves the
game
so again the zigzag maneuver does the
trick check
check
and only now you go king b6 the white
queen is dominated there's no checks and
mate happens in the next move
the best attempt here is queen c6 check
if you find yourself in this position do
this
but of course king takes c6 wins not
queen takes c6 that's stalemate
so the same by the way can happen with a
bishop on so in certain situations where
the king is close enough
it is still winning but
you know whether or not it's winning
really depends on exactly where the king
is
okay
i think that's enough
i think that's enough
see you guys tomorrow thanks again
[Music]
you